bildung und eine andere meldung die uns
heute ja in aufschrecken ließ sind
geheime pläne von wladimir putin die
bekannt geworden sind es sind noch
spekulationen aber die sind bekannt
geworden wie er die ukraine
erobern will und was er mit ihr vorhat
und das steht drin nachdem
operationsplan von russland sollen bis
zu 2000 spezialkräfte mindestens einen
von zwei flughäfen in kiew einnehmen
außerdem sollen bis zu 10.000 weitere
fallschirmjäger mit leicht gepanzerten
fahrzeugen in der hauptstadt eintreffen
und eine der aufgaben besteht darin die
ukrainische regierung zu fassen und sie
durch zu zwingen ein abkommen zu
russlands bedingungen zu unterzeichnen
außerdem wenn die führung kiews
evakuiert wird soll ein pro russischer
politiker die regierung unter dem
vorwand übernehmen das die alte
regierung geflohen sein und das ergebnis
ist dass die ukraine in zwei teile
geteilt werden kann nach dem prinzip von
west und ostdeutschland oder auch nord-
und
südkorea das sind also geheimpläne die
ukrainische
spezialeinheiten zur einnahme kurs durch
fallschirmjäger aufgedeckt haben wollen
die meldung kommt von der ukrainischen
nachrichtenagentur
nexxter könnte das wirklich so kommen
ist das realistisch die ukraine geteilt
so wie es deutschland einst war in ost
und west bei uns im studio ist der bild
live chef claus strunz wir uns mal
durchgehen klaus guten morgen ja also
das finde ich erklärt vieles von dem was
wir erlebt haben in den letzten tagen
die fragen waren ja immer macht er das
wirklich nimmt er das ganze land besetzt
der kf und es wirkte alles so schaut
nach dem motto schauen wir mal aber das
was jetzt offenbar geworden ist es sind
ukrainische quälen das muss man sich
vielleicht einmal doch dazu klar machen
auch da kann bestimmte propaganda drin
stecken aber die plausibilität die
innere wahrheit dessen ist so bestechen
wie erschreckend zugleich und ich glaube
wenn jetzt in deutschland noch jemand
lebt der sagt das geht mich nichts an
dann rückt diese vorstellung dass die
ukraine geteilt wird in west und ost wie
einst deutschland in die bundesrepublik
und die ddr übrigens nach einer
ähnlichen logik der ostteil gehört
sozusagen jetzt vereinfacht gesagt zu
russland sowjetunion und der westteil
gehört zur westlichen welt mit all den
dingen des kalten kriegs die sich daraus
ergeben haben da fehlt wenn man ist
jetzt sozusagen zugespitzt formulieren
will eigentlich dann nur noch die mauer
die quer durch die ukraine geht aber ist
es nicht widersprüchlich zu dem was wir
berichten unsere reporter philipp
potthoff die ganzen tage schon in
lemberg also einer stadt sehr weit im
westen an der grenze zu polen die er
auch angegriffen wird beziehungsweise in
der nähe fanden angriffe statt warum
dann das also ich glaube dass das
logisch ist so unlogisch wie es klingt
und zwar weil wladimir putin am ende der
kriegshandlungen ja etwas für den
kompromiss braucht politik funktioniert
ja immer in der oftmals in friedlichen
zeiten
logischen art und weise eines
kompromisses in kriegs und
auseinandersetzungen oft im perversen
mittel des kompromisses und was ich
damit meine ist
wenn wladimir putin die gesamte ukraine
einnimmt aber sein eigentliches ziel ist
nicht dann polen und deutschland und was
alles schon an die wand gemalt worden
ist sondern sein eigentliches ziel ist
eine ost ukraine zu schaffen lasst uns
mal an die karte gegen die hause können
uns manchmal spannend wer wirklich
interessant kann man mir dieses mal
anschauen an der karte wenn wir uns mal
anschauen das ist die ukraine ich habe
ja mal ein bisschen aufgezogen so dass
man noch mal sieht das ist deutschland
das ist die ene das sind nur nicht das
wird nur 1200 kilometer luftlinie
zwischen kiew und berlin das sind unsere
nachbarn wir sind also mitten in europa
so jetzt schauen wir mal hier auf die
ukraine ich mach das nochmal weg und
schiebt das noch mal ein bisschen drüber
damit für die hier größer haben also ein
riesiges gebiet hier ist lemberg das ist
der westen das ist die zentrale stadt
des westens das ist knifflig markiere
das mal das ist der osten hier um die
jan kleinen fleck ging es eigentlich nur
die ganze zeit nur das hat daten wir
dachten wir es erst jedes punkten hier
die krim hier unten die schon 2014 die
er sich schon 2014 geklaut hat muss man
so sagen so jetzt ist die frage was ist
strategisch für ihn wichtig in dieser
kleine das ist das schwarze meer hier
ist die schwarzmeerflotte der zugang zum
schwarzen meer es für ihn wichtig das
heißt all das hier diese ganze küste bis
nach odessa oder auch schon angegriffen
worden hier das ist die schwarzmeerküste
das ist also der logische punkte wenn
wir jetzt an eine teilung denken wo
könnte die verlaufen kiew die hauptstadt
dann kann man eigentlich hier so
ungefähr den strich ziehen und ich
glaube wenn man das vor augen hat diese
karte mit dieser logik dann wird ein
vieles von der strategischen von der
militärstrategie putins klar es hätte
eines eine logik wenn man auch das
danach mit einbezieht dass er erst auch
diesen teil mit besetzt
natürlich die regierung in kiel verjagt
oder festnimmt oder noch schlimmeres und
dann sagt mir gehört jetzt die ganze
ukraine lieber westen und es soll auch
so bleiben und dann wird der westen in
verhandlungen eintreten und dann wird
man sich einigen das ungefähr sagen wir
mal das kommt dann auf die verhandlungen
an hier oder hier
denn drin strich verläuft und dann
gewinnt er das was er von anfang an
haben wollte dadurch dass er das
angedroht hat noch haben zu wollen das
ist wenn die überzeugende logik sondern
auch das auto kommt noch einen punkt
hinzu meines erachtens wenn er das ganze
hätte dann hätte er direkten kontakt zur
eu und zur nato
das ist die grenze hier zwischen ja
holen polen ist ein nato land ja hier
sind wir in rumänien rumänien gehört zur
eu wenn er das nicht nehmen würde dann
wäre der direkte kontakt vermieden was
auch im interesse des westens was musst
dann das hauptinteresse des westens sein
denn umgekehrt gilt ja auch da wollen
wir wirklich nicht mehr da war und dann
kristallisiert sich doch raus die
hauptstadt der ost ukraine bleibt kiew
unter einer russisch dominierten
regierung und für die hauptstadt der
west ukraine bietet sich lemberg an mit
der direkten nähe zum westen das
erscheint geostrategisch so sinnvoll
dass es obwohl es bisher geheimen
papiere sind die keiner bestätigt den
charme und den zwang der inneren
wahrheit hat als ich dass mir jetzt
überlegt habe ist mir klar geworden
deshalb funktioniert der angriff wieder
funktioniert genau und dann hätten wir
letztendlich das werden wir das hier
haben dieses szenario hätten wir das was
wir auch hier hatten mal in deutschland
und das weckt ja nur alle damit
verbundenen erinnerungen also nicht nur
die zwischenmenschlichen erinnerungen
getrennte familien etc sondern dass er
weg eben auch das sich entlang dieser
grenze ein jahrzehnte langer kalter
krieg zugetragen hat zwischen einem west
bündnis in einem ost bündnis und wenn
man sich dann rein denkt das ist ladina
putin womöglich gelingt die chinesen an
seine seite zu kriegen dann wird einem
angst und bange
wir gehen zurück in dem sandra wieder in
die mitte hier an diesem tag an dem ja
immer mehr dramatische nachrichten
herein kommt eine gerade beispielsweise
auch russland bringt fallschirmjäger
nach tschernobyl tschernobyl wir wissen
alle die
reaktorkatastrophe dort und feser frau
feser nancy faeser die
bundesinnenministerium bekräftigt an
nein zu waffenlieferungen an die ukraine
natürlich auch ein sehr umstrittenes
thema sie lenski der ukrainische
präsident hat gefleht geradezu darum
jetzt waffen zu bekommen auch jürgen
trittin hat noch mal gesagt nein das
machen wir nicht das bringt nichts das
hilft auch nichts da eine mahnung
eigentlich glaube ja wenn wenn die
menschen in der ukraine uns hier so zu
hören wie wir diesen konflikt
diskutieren erste these ist immer was
lernen wir jetzt für die zukunft daraus
das hilft den menschen dort gar nix 0
brauchen jetzt hilfe dann hört man immer
also keine waffen weil es ist halt kein
nato-land ich sage jetzt dazu pech
gehabt da hätte es hat geklappt mit dem
nato-beitritt dann hätten wir jetzt den
bündnisfall so können wir euch leider
nicht helfen ich glaube das ist für den
westen keine durch haltbare seriöse
politik wenn er nicht gleichzeitig viel
stärker als bisher deutlich macht wie
man denn helfen will wo ist denn der
humanitären korridor durch die ukraine
nach polen in den westen den mann
schützt das könnte man sogar mitten im
defensiven mandat der verteidigung und
mit einem bezug auf humanismus und
menschenrechte wo sind denn die großen
hilfslieferungen ich habe noch kein
callboy gesehen der da irgendwie essen
und trinken dahin bringt das könnte man
machen in zeiten sozusagen zivil zu
helfen das alles könnte man machen aber
macht nichts wir haben das muss man
einfach einmal in der deutlichkeit
feststellen der westen hat beschlossen
die menschen in der ukraine jetzt im
stich zu lassen und wladimir putin und
seinen soldaten auszuliefern und dann
will man mal gucken was das bedeutet und
was daraus folgt für mich ist es
wirklich schwer zu ertragen und das
führt zu der frage die sich jeder von
uns stellen muss jeder denn sonst
gehören mit gehören wir alle zu der
zurzeit größten armee der welt nämlich
den lava privaten die immer alles
möglich labern und erzählen usw wir
müssen uns die frage stellen werden wir
selber bereit für die freiheit der
ukraine zu kämpfen und zu bezahlen und
zu bezahlen konnten uns immer vorstellen
deutschland hat immer alles mit geld
erledigt immer alles mit geld erledigt
war hell michigan wirtschaftliche
unterstützung und so weiter aber wären
wir bereit ist es hohe gut der freiheit
zu verteidigen während wir bereits
zusagen bundeswehr wird jetzt in echten
alarmzustand versetzt weil nämlich sie
dazu da ist die nato ostgrenze zu
sichern wären wir bereit das dann auch
ein bundeswehr flugzeug abgeschossen
wird mit dem piloten da drin der dann
tot ist werden mehr bereit das alles zu
tun und ich glaube freiheit für die
ukraine mit martialischen mitteln zu
fördern kann nur der der am ende auch
dazu bereit wäre am ende geht es doch
jetzt darum an dieser grenze wie wir
dahin gezeigt zwischen polen und der
ukraine
die waffen zu zeigen wir müssen doch
jetzt als westen als nato wladimir putin
folgendes zeigen wir haben mehr panzer
als du wir haben die besseren flieger
als du wir haben mehr leute als du wir
haben mehr unterstützung als du wir
haben alles viel mehr als du und wir
werden es auch einsetzen wenn du es
wagst das nato gebiet zu bedrohen oder
setzt das alles höre ich aber nicht ich
höre von sondersitzungen von beschlüssen
der deutsche bundestag bringt es fertig
am sonntag erst zu tagen also sozusagen
in nochmal zwei tagen statt sofort
einzuberufen wir machen quasi ein
bisschen erweitert des business as usual
sowie der westen sich so eine krise
vorstellt und derweil starben in der
ukraine die leute oder vielleicht
verhungern sie beide in jedem fall
flüchten sie und wenn sie noch
rauskommen kommen sie natürlich in den
westen für die männer sieht es ja wenn
die nachrichten stand stimmt schlecht
aus denn die sind durch die
generalmobilmachung ja eigentlich
verpflichtet sozusagen ihr land zu
verteidigen wir treiben also sogar noch
die männer die männlichen ukraine in
diesen krieg hinein das ist aus meiner
sicht schon
also nicht nur einzigartig darüber haben
wir glaube ich konstant sondern das wird
lange nachhallen auch was die moralische
reputation des westens angeht nun könnte
man sagen und gott das ist
kriegstreiberei und das mal den
schrecken an die wand erstaunlicherweise
wir haben gerade mit jürgen trittin
gesprochen der genau über das erreichen
aber ich will auch mal sein dieses
kriegstreiberei argument hat uns doch
die ganze zeit davon abgehalten unseren
verpflichtungen in der nato nachzukommen
wegen genau dieses argument war es der
politik nicht möglich zu sagen dass wir
so viel mit so viel geld uns an der nato
beteiligen müssen wie wir es eigentlich
müssten zwei prozent unserer
wirtschaftsleistung zahlen wir seit
jahren nicht bezahlen es einfach nicht
weil wir nämlich immer gedacht haben
passiert schon nicht kommt schon nicht
brauchen wir nicht wir lachen uns seit
jahren kaputt der beste party gag und
der beste stand ist dass unsere panzer
nicht funktionieren und unsere flieger
nicht fliegen und unsere kunden nicht
mehr auftauchen und keine ahnung was
jetzt ist es aber so dass wir sie
gebrauchen könnten im schwarzen meer und
an der polnischen grenze und das alles
ist so beklemmend dass ich glaube dass
man sagen kann corona hat uns all unsere
sünden der wohlstandsverwahrlosung
aufgezeigt im zivilen leben
digitalisierung ich muss nicht aufzählen
wir kennen das alle und dieser konflikt
zeigt uns all unsere sünden der
wohlstandsverwahrlosung aus bei der
frage der selbstverteidigung sind
wertlos wenn uns jemand angreift iphones
meister der heeres inspekteur der
oberste deutsche soldat hat gestern auch
gesagt wir stehen blank da als
bundeswehr ich würde jetzt gerne helfen
können aber ich kann es gar nicht und
das alles weiß wladimir putin ja auch
und was war an der wand waren und noch
an der wand und gezeichnet haben was mir
auch noch mal klar geworden ist einen
solchen plan
hat man ja nicht abends beim bierchen
sondern er ist natürlich da steht
natürlich seid wahrscheinlich jahren
fest wenn ich das heute richtig
verstanden habe von peter tiede unserem
korrespondenten war auch allen klar dass
immer geheimdiplomatie stattgefunden hat
zu dieser frage und dann hat dieser mann
mit seinen schergen um sich herum
dieses geplant und während er schon
wusste welche schachfigur wann zieht
hatte die ganzen westlichen politiker
antanzen lassen die dann da irgendwas
erzählt haben von rückzug und so weiter
durch sagt ja rückzug der hat uns doch
alle an der nase herumgeführt spätestens
2014 als er sich die creme geholt hat
wird er gewusst haben wie er auch weiter
und da 1 vielleicht noch das hat mich
das hat mich durch die nacht begleitet
weil in diesem studio ich gestern haben
die möglichkeit hatte mit peter altmaier
zu sprechen der dann gesagt hat an der
krimm habe man ja sehen können da haben
wir auch schon mit steigen
wirtschaftssanktionen reagiert und das
sei das richtige signal das ist
natürlich ein schwieriges argument denn
genau umgekehrt würden schuh draus die
waren so schwach die sanktionen gegen
putin dass er es geschafft hat dieses
super her und diese super armee zu
ermächtigen jetzt ein nachbar zu
überfallen also wenn man noch eines
beweises bedurft hätte dass es ein
stumpfes schwert sein kann
wirtschaftssanktionen gegen einen
diktator dann ist der umgang mit der
krim und dieses verhalten des westens
nach der annexion der krim das beste
beispiel dafür